the White House is criticizing House
Democrats for widening their
investigation of President Trump press
secretary Sarah Sanders said quote their
intimidation and abuse of American
citizens is shameful the president
called it ridiculous but promised to
cooperate I can operate all the time
with everybody the House Judiciary
Committee wants documents from 81 Trump
associates and institutions including
the president's sons former White House
aides and Trump Organization executives
Paula Reid is at the White House Paula
quite a list good morning it is quite a
list John and Judiciary Committee
Chairman Jerry Nadler says this
investigation will look into possible
obstruction corruption and abuse of
power by the Trump administration and
those targeted in this document grab
have just two weeks to comply otherwise
they could be hit with a subpoena the
White House confirms it has received the
request and says they will do everything
they can to comply but Democrats may be
hindered if the president wants to
assert executive privilege over certain
items that could set off a lengthy court
fight and delay the investigations now
the committee's ranking Republican Doug
Collins dismissed the wide-ranging
investigation as quote recklessly
prejudging the president now as
Democrats are ramping up these
investigations Washington continues to
be on high alert for a final report from
special counsel robert muller but
neither says he can't wait for Muller he
wants to begin gathering these documents
to quote start building the public
record
bianna the urgency intensified can I
just say Paul on a separate note that is
a beautiful live shot this morning it
looks like a halo behind you at the
sunrise thank you